[Musique]
mieux dans le débat sur france 24 g - 10
avant le second tour de la
présidentielle emmanuel macron et marine
le pen remonte au front au havre pour
lui avignon pour elle emmanuel macron a
accès ce déplacement sur le thème de
l'écologie la population du havre a voté
en majorité pour jean luc mélenchon
comme la ville d'avignon au premier tour
mais le vaucluse est un département
acquis au rassemblement national à
l'objectif bien sûr de tenter de
mobiliser l'électorat de jean luc
mélenchon convaincre les indécis et les
12 8 millions de personnes qui se sont
abstenus au premier tour selon le
sondage ipsos et sopra et steria les
intentions de vote sont de 55% pour
emmanuel macron contre 45% pour marine
le pen vous le voyez alors ce match
macron le pen est finalement de france
qui s'oppose comment convaincre les
abstentionnistes et ceux qui ont voté
justement pour le leader de la france a
soumises où en est ce match à dix jours
du scrutin vendée battre avec mes
invités j'ai le plaisir d'avoir à mes
côtés michèle cotta bonsoir journaliste
politique vous avez été également jeudi
pour notre public international qui ne
le sait peut-être pas directrice de
france 2 directrice de l'information de
tf1 présidente également de la haute
autorité de la communication
merci d'être avec nous michèle cotta en
face de vous mathieu doiret bonsoir
mathieu doiret directeur d'études
d'ipsos bienvenue à vous parler vite
avec nous bonsoir paulo correspondant à
paris de l' agence de presse italienne
landes ça et puis en face de vous jean
sébastien ferjou bonsoir directeur et
fondateur de l'atlantique au mathieu
doiret l'on regardé justement puisqu'on
a partenariat avec vous vos derniers
chiffres selon les sondages ipsos sopra
et steria les intentions de vote sont
donc deux 55% pourrait mener le
maquereau contre 45% pour marine le pen
c'est un match plutôt stable depuis
dimanche oui
mesures tous les jours des intentions de
vote n'ont pas non plus changé depuis
hier
ce qui signifie que ce qu'on observe
dans les reports de voix potentielles ne
bouge pas non plus beaucoup
et que à vrai dire ce combat pour les
électeurs de jean luc mélenchon reste
pertinent de toute évidence qu'on
n'irait martin ont maintenant notamment
le fait qu'à qu'une part très importante
de cet électorat est encore indécis
c'est à dire pour être bien s'abstenir
en fait le 24 avril d'après vos chiffres
à 33 % des électeurs de mélenchon au
premier tour seraient prêts à voter pour
emmanuel macron c'est bien ça celui-ci
18 pour marine le pen 49 % préfèrent
voter blanc ou nul de l'as et ça en fait
la vraie incertitude c'est ce qu'ils
vont rester dans l'abstention blancs ou
nuls ou ce qu'ils vont basculer au final
pour l'un ou l'autre des candidats alors
probablement jamais intégralement ses
49% vont pas se reporter intégralement
sur l'un des deux héros soyons clair
dans le cas de marine le pen c'est ce
qui lui serait nécessaire quand même
pour gravir les dix points qui lui reste
à accomplir il faudrait donc capter plus
de 20%
et a besoin de 10 % michèle cotta quel
est pour vous l'enjeu de ce second tour
justement c'est récupérer cet électorat
populaire mélenchonistes dans un paysage
politique français qui est vraiment
contrairement à ce qui s'est toujours
passé avec marie avec marine le pen et
avec son père d'ailleurs cette fois ci
il a des réserves bon elle n'avait pas
les autres fois c'est à dire au fond le
jeu était plié
au bout du premier tour c'est là
évidemment l'enjeu est considérable
parce que bien sûr elle a des réserves
sur sa droite mais que la campagne de
jean luc mélenchon d'une certaine façon
peut l'aider à trouver des électeurs
parmi ceux qui trouvent que franchement
mâcon n'a jamais rien fait pour eux cas
de france la france qui souffre la
france qui profite la france des pauvres
la france des riches là dessus quand
même le discours de mélenchon a été
souvent analogue à celui de marine le
pen sans le social sur le social sur sur
les riches sur la l'archipel isation
française discours ont été bas et donc
est ce que dans les 49 dit qu'ils
hésitent à y aura plus de mai l'ancien
mélenchonistes pas voter pour le pen que
d'anciens bonne chose un voté pou
macumba c'est vrai que c'est tout là
toute la question c'est souverain c'est
toute la question jean sébastien ferjou
le vote contestataire est très élevé en
france ça fait partie de cette nouvelle
architecture française on se retrouve
avec finalement trois blocs de blog
contestataire qui sont ces deux blocs
radicaux à gauche et à droite et puis ce
bloc au centre est ce que finalement il
ya une agrégation au des colères
non il ya un cumul des colères mais qui
ne s'additionnent pas parce que l'on
politique vous pouvez pas juste
additionné des électorats les uns les
uns après les autres mais c'est vrai que
la spécificité de 2022 probablement
quand je regardais y avait plus plus ou
moins quatre candidats du système en
quelque sorte et huit candidats se
revendiquant à des degrés différents
m plutôt anti système et il me semble
que pour la première fois vous avez
quand même eu une majorité de gens qui
se sont portés justement sur des
candidat antisystème le sujet c'est que
sont pas des gens qui ce n'est pas parce
que vous êtes d'accord pour rejeter
quelque chose que vous êtes d'accord
pour souhaiter pour souhaiter la même
chose parce que effectivement il ya
beaucoup de convergences entre les
programmes de jean-luc mélenchon et de
marine le pen et même quand vous
regarder l'attitude sur le quinquennat
que ça a été au moment d'un gilet jaune
sur la vaccination sur des tas de sujets
la manière dont a été géré la pandémie
finalement sur tous les sujets à
l'exception de l'immigré
est quand même de la gestion de l'ordre
de la gestion de l'ordre public il ya
quasiment une convergence absolue et ce
sont clairement des gens qui pourraient
je sais pas si on était en allemagne se
mettent autour d'une table et négocier
un programme de gouvernement sauf que ce
qui les sépare est quasi insurmontable
et c'était aussi une des nouveautés de
d'ailleurs de l'élection 2022 c'est
qu'on le voit en regardant la carte du
vote jean luc mélenchon le vote
communautaire mais c'était préfigurer
depuis longtemps on l'a vu aussi dans un
certain nombre d'ouvragés comme celui de
jérôme fourquet sur l'archipel isation
la société français il y a désormais
aussi un vote communautaire qui est
capable de peser au niveau national mais
c'est aussi ce qui fait que de toute
façon le résultat du deuxième tour et
sauf accident énormissime scandale
intersidéral visant même macron les la
marche est de toute façon à mon sens
trop tour marine le pen ololé vie alors
justement votre vision de journalistes
italiens sur ce match macron le pen sur
ce vote contestataire française que vous
faites par exemple un parallèle avec la
montée en puissance à une époque parce
que c'est moins le cas aujourd'hui de
matteo salvini écoute et oui chez nous
on a eu une convergence des luttes en
2013 on a eu une sorte de mouvement ou
qui avait vu une agrégation presque de
d'une force semblable à celle de jean
luc mélenchon de gauche radicale avec
l'extrême droite et tout ça a donné lieu
à un grand mouvement qui s'appelait le
mouvement 5 étoiles qui ensuite pendant
dix ans il a gravi tous les échelons du
pouvoir et il est arrivé jusqu'au
gouvernement il ya quelques années ça a
été une expérience de gouvernement assez
pitoyable qui qui ensuite est c'est très
très très mal fini et aujourd'hui il ya
un retour en italie un petit peu à la
compétence parce qu'on a compris que
surtout en ce moment on n'est pas en
train de vivre un moment normal de notre
histoire c'est pas on est en train de
traverser en italie mais en europe de
façon peu plus large un manque crucial
où on voit vraiment les clivages qui se
dessine pas seulement au niveau national
mais au niveau de grand bloc et on le
voit très bien avec la chine ou avec la
russie qui aujourd'hui menace donc cette
élection elle est fondamentale pour
l'enterrer mode de vie et notre
démocratie européenne est donc l'enjeu
de ce scrutin je dirais même à une
portée aujourd'hui éminemment très
européenne et les yeux de l'europe
entière sont braqués ces jours ci sur
sur la france parce que ce qui se joue
le 24 avril je sais pas si tous les
français les électeurs français en sont
conscients mais aura un impact direct
sur la vie de tous les autres citoyens
européens en italie en allemagne en
espagne et sur le processus
d'intégration européenne d'auxerre c'est
un bol vraiment très très important et
où se joue l'avenir de l'europe on va
revenir justement sur ces divergences
sur l'europe entre ces deux candidats
métier doit être d'abord pourquoi marine
le pen fait-elle moins peur par exemple
il ya cinq ans ben c'est vrai qu'elle
ait les mêmes surprenamment une des
candidates qui rassure le plus alors
d'abord parce que en anglais on dit dans
des verrines au et c'est vrai que
finalement elle fait partie du paysage
depuis quand même maintenant pas mal de
temps et puis ça ne suffit pas quand
même ça non mais elle n'a cessé quand
même de dévier vers la gauche d'ailleurs
c'est quand même fondamentalement ce qui
a donné naissance au phénomène zemmour
et c'est une évidence parce que d'abord
c'était un pari qu'elle a fait quand
elle a voulu rompre avec l'héritage de
son père en 2010 quand elle a pris le
contrôle du disque était à l'époque le
front national elle a fait un pari très
sarkozyste dans la dire qu'ils étaient
de s'adresser à une coalition très large
qu'irait de l'électorat populaire à
l'électorat le plus conservateur sur
l'électorat le plus conservateur s'est
très vite heurtés à sa nièce et et à une
conception de l'extrême-droite comme une
des composantes de la droite
conservatrice traditionnelle et elle
n'est pas à l'aise avec ça pour plein de
raisons d une raison de manifestement
d'abord c'est que il faut quand même le
dire que la tradition de la peine c'est
que le pouvoir ne se partage pas ni dans
l'appareil ni potentiellement ensuite
dans l'exercice des responsabilités et
qui sont quand même à peu près incapable
de gérer des coalitions on l'a vu dans
les municipalités les conseils régionaux
donc la réalité de le pen c'est que
c'est une populiste personnaliste
exactement dans la veine de
donald trump c'est à dire que l'aller le
début et la fin des l'alpha et l'oméga
de son programme politique michèle cotta
emmanuel macron à d'ailleurs affirmé
qu'il ne fallait plus miser sur la
diabolisation justement de marine le pen
uniquement justement en plus il ya des
années il ya un an ou deux vous répétez
beaucoup d'hommes politiques du centre
qui disent elle a tort de faire ça parce
que l'extrême droite doit être quelque
chose de contraire très autocrate et
elle a complètement tort de se
dédiaboliser mais en fait d'abord elle a
eu raison sa stratégie a montré qu'elle
était quand même payant et deuxièmement
elle a été formidablement aider il faut
bien dire par eric zemmour scories au
départ elles étaient plutôt orthez il
est étonnant de voir le corps des
exams aura tellement paru comme plus
radicale qu'elle il a tellement pris le
seul comme seul thème celui de
l'immigration qui lui a laissé tout
loisir wen a pas de preuve a donné l sur
l'immigration c'est ce qu'elle pense bon
ça lui a donné au contraire à marine le
pen le loisir de développer son
programme sur le pouvoir d'achat donc
l'alliance des deux a été clique pas
assez
mortels pour eric zemmour en tout cas et
lui a profité au fis tableau elle donc
ça veut dire on des on ne peut plus
diaboliser marine le pen c'est ce que
dit emmanuel macron en fait ça peut plus
être seulement ça sa colère elle peut
alors on peut l'attaquer sur d'autres
choses on peut l'attaquer effectivement
sur l'europe sur sa conception de
l'europe et ça on l'a bien vu dans la
conférence de presse d'hier on peut
l'attaquer aussi sur un certain
populisme ou sur ses amitiés
avec urban qui définit quand même par
exemple gordon notamment qui définit sa
conscience à démocratie on va l'attaquer
sur ça mais on ne peut pas dire c'est
une dame plutôt sympathique que tient le
coup dans les meetings alors qu'on on a
vu que pour les meetings pour les femmes
ça pourrait être très difficile qui a
des chats qui habite tout seul raté
toute chose il faut pas seulement en
fait c'est qu'ils ont eue manises ayons
une analyse qui blanchira qu'ils aient
ouvert parce qu'elle est encore
d'extrême droite ou pas parce que marcel
gauchet qui était à gauche enfin il
n'est pas aussi plus grand des marchés
le gaucher pas ce que lui dit qu'elle
n'est pas d'extrême droite jean
sébastien ferjou
il ya marine le pen il ya un
rassemblement national après il ya
l'électorat qui peut se retrouver sur le
rassemblement national et je pense que
selon que vous considérez l'une ou
l'autre de ces trois réalités la réponse
n'est pas la même je crois pas que
marine le pen soit d'extrême droite je
pense qu'effectivement elle est une
populiste oui assez personnaliste
effectivement c'est aller son propre
programme en quelque sorte où elle est
aussi elle s'adapte en tout à l'air du
temps elle est la somme des
mécontentements à un moment donné il ya
au rassemblement national une filiation
d'extrême droite historique
intellectuelle idéologique mais je ne
crois pas que ça représente la majorité
du rassemblement national aujourd'hui
encore moins dans la mesure où cette
partie là est plutôt tous quitté le
navire et est allé chez eric zemmour
d'ailleurs c'était intéressant de voir
en creux marine le pen en dix ans b
regardez il ya des nazis maintenant dans
son entourage oui tiens donc il était
donc que vous les connaissez il était
chez vous avant enfin bon bah et
l'électorat qui je crois n'est pas du
tout d'extrême droite c'est un électorat
qui plus tôt et dans une forme
il ya une vraie adhésion il peut y avoir
une vraie adhésion aux fondements de ce
qu'est la vision toujours du
rassemblement national et qui est le
rejet d'une immigration incontrôlée ou
alors à sa vision
social après je ne crois pas que
l'électorat au sens large serait séduit
par une candidate qui serait j'ai pas
quoiqu'il se proposeraient de réduire la
démo le champ démocratique
français ou quoi que ce soit de cet
ordre là michèle cotta vous êtes
d'accord il ya des façons différentes de
réduire le champ de la démocratie quand
même on n'est pas obligé de dire non à
la gestion qui est faite c'est à dire
que naturellement on ne réduira jamais
et puis quand finalement on décide peler
les lois européennes ne s'impose pas aux
lois françaises
donc on met en cause les gens qui
pensent le contraire quand on voit très
bien le combat pour la démocratie est un
combat qui se gagnent chaque jour et moi
personnellement je ne suis pas sûr que
ce soit le combat vital de marine le pen
et quand je dis que j'en suis pas sûr je
suis sûr c'est un euphémisme en fait non
c'est ça voulait dire pas le lévis alors
justement cette dé diabolisation de
l'extrême droite on l'a vu en italie oui
absolument parallèle vous les médias
italiens allemands aujourd'hui disons
que en observant les visions de
winnenden parallèle parce que je sais
pas si je sais pas si tu es intimement
marine le pen dans l'échiquier politique
si elle est d'extrême droite ou de
droite radicale aux deux jeunes heures
serait ce qu elle droite en tout cas je
le regard de son programme et en
regardant son programme disons la grande
priorité de son programme c'est quelque
chose qui revendiquait dans notre pays
aussi en italie par giorgia meloni qui
elle du coup elle est d'extrême droite
et l'homme marine de plaies peine à dans
le symbole des gens de sa famille
politique traditionnelle la flamme
tricolore est là l introduction de la
priorité nationale qui scella est quand
même mesure extrêmement d'extrême droite
sur cela il y a aucun doute il y a aussi
un repli identitaire et nationaliste
revendiquer chaque jour dans ses
meetings dans ses interviews où elle dit
qu'elle veut remplacer disons notre
magnifique aventure européenne à travers
une alliance de nation donc je sais pas
si l intime moment elle est plus modérée
que 500 carrière historique de
l'extrême-droite un joueur s'il ya un
débat où on a décidé une fois pour
toutes que nous fassions il ya des
sujets et des questions qui étaient
interdites au peuple français mais dans
ce cas là ne nous ont plus d'élections
non plus parce que la démocratie me
semble c'est précisément d'être capable
d'entendre que les peuples restent
souvent il n'y a rien dans la
constitution européenne il dans le droit
européen qui décide que justement les
français auraient perdu leur
souveraineté donc le sujet ça n'est pas
que marine le pen on puisse goûter oui
ça je suis assez d'accord on peut
raisonnablement douter de l'appétence
démocratique de marine eux-mêmes pris
dans l'autre sens qu'est ce qu'une
démocratie qui par nature à enlever des
pans entiers de la décision politique en
la bhl la mettant dans des blocs de
constitutionnalité dans du droit à
reperdre parce que peu importe que ça a
été validé par un certain nombre de
traités vous voyez bien que la
jurisprudence elle est allée beaucoup
plus loin que ce qui bien souvent est l
intention et au delà de ça au delà de ça
le sujet est-ce que l'irréversibilité
est un principe démocratique est ce que
les peuples cite il s'ils ont envie de
remettre en cause un certain nombre de
choix politiques ont été faits au niveau
européen doivent être absolument
interdit le faire vitam aeternam c'est
une vraie question démocratique voulait
rebondir peut-être vous aimez vous avec
marine le pen elle était très attention
à ce qu'elle dit on le voit très bien
dans son programme elle ne met pas en
tête de son programme l'état il n'y a
qu'à la fin on s'aperçoit que
l'allemagne est un partenaire
insupportable que le couple franco
allemand est à battre que d'ailleurs les
allemands achètent américain et puis il
ya qu'à la fin
qu'elle dit dans la faim et qu'elle dit
on ne supportera pas que les lois que
les lois d'euros europe elle s'applique
à notre à nos codes c'est une façon elle
a masqué saison l agence parce que c'est
pas une façon de dire mais moi je
comprends très bien qu'on critique
l'europe et qu'on ne veuille pas
d'europe mais c'est une façon de masquer
ses parts de 10 mais ne dément pas c'est
de dire qu'on peut souhaiter une autre
europe c'est encore là on va on va
justement évoqué manel emmanuel macron
comment justement mathieu doiret
mène-t-il cette nouvelle bataille
finalement pour le second tour
effectivement il ne veut plus ne parie
plus sur la diabolisation de marine le
pen lui dit maintenant vouloir mener une
bataille projet contre projet est ce que
ça veut dire est ce que c'est une
clarification sa stratégie oui enfin
c'est surtout lié au fait que l'essence
même du populisme a là encore une fois à
la trump à ce que je pense que parler
d'exploit tu ne sers à rien en fait
c'est effectivement il s'agit là il a
compris en réalité le problème du
populisme cd de chercher des solutions
simplistes à des problèmes compliqués et
ça marche d'autant mieux que les gens
effectivement le sentiment que les
problèmes sont rendus compliqués
sciemment par les élites donc il ya tout
l'idée que en réalité ce qui était
compliqué pourrait être simple que l'on
vous fait croire que c'est compliqué
pour que vous soyez disciplinés que vous
acceptiez confèrent les règles
sanitaires par exemple sur la colline
que vous accepter des contraintes donc
en fait le principe de mâcon ça va être
de dire oui très bien ok je suis
d'accord avec vous là dessus là dessus
mais alors comment on fait alors ses
traders c'est très dangereux quand c'est
avec des des fous furieux comme ceux qui
croisent la plupart du temps dans les
rues parce que je comprends cette
volonté de dire moi je n'ai pas peur du
débat avec les citoyens la réalité c'est
ben voilà alors il est en dessous de ça
va mais les débats avec les gilet jaune
ça sert à rien donc c'était au havre
ouais mais c'est en alsace par exemple
il a eu des discussion surréaliste non
la réalité c'est qu'il faut qu'il montre
qu'il n'a pas peur d'eux effectivement
de défendre son projet qui n'a rien à
cacher ça c'est important qui a pas
d'agenda secret pour ça d'ailleurs qu'il
est même prêt à mettre beaucoup d'eau
dans son vin d'un autre côté il a
impatience je pense de m marine le pen
devant ses contradictions et l on
remarquera qu'elle ne se heurte jamais à
des constructeurs pour le moment là on
voit en alsace à michèle cotta justement
est ce que c'est une bonne stratégie de
la part des malades de dire qu'il veut
faire du projet contre projet est-ce que
c'est porteur pour les dix jours qui
viennent seulement drôle c'est leur
attitude qui a été vraiment
rigoureusement opposée depuis le départ
il y en a un qui ne va que dans les
endroits où il a perdu c'est emmanuel
macron et l'autre qui ne voit que dans
les endroits où elle est sûre de gagner
qui est marine le pen verra c'est vrai
que c'est une stratégie de campagne mais
qui correspond un peu à au tempérament
qu'on connaît à emmanuel macron c'est à
dire qu'au fond lui il s'ennuie quand
tout et quand tout est plat ce qui
l'amusé d'aller essayer de tirer une
phrase de quelqu'un qui possiblement ne
votera pas pour lui mais c'est son
ressort on l'a bien vu aux ondes et
gilet jaune et donc il exploitera
l'exploitera pendant cette deuxième
partie d'une certification notamment car
il n'a pas d'autant plus qu'il n'a pas
du tout employé avant donc bon il fait
campagne à sa façon je sais pas si c'est
efficace je sais pas s'ils arrivent à
déplacer les votes ou les convictions
des gens c'est sa manière à lui et on ne
se refait pas sans tourner quand on est
assez sympa mais politique ou une femme
politique faut pas essayer d'aller
contre son tempérament turrel son
tempérament et celui-là mais c'est ça
c'est certainement son compère amont et
effectivement après je remarque que
c'est quand même avec un peu plus de
nuances dans la stratégie ser oui il va
dans des zones effet dimanche
entièrement d'accord est ce que disait
michèle cotta contrairement à marine le
pen où elle évite de semaine dans des
situations de danger mais on peut la
comprendre aussi parce qu'en terme
d'image on voit bien que l il faut à
tout prix qu'elle ait l'air d'être une
candidate apaisé et pas qu'elle soit une
candidate confronté justement à ce qui
pourrait ressembler à des affrontements
trouvé en maintenant mais neil mc ren il
le fait quand même avec subtilité vous
remarquerez sur l'afpa lundi par mardy
par exemple il finissait la journée à
strasbourg sur la place de la cathédrale
de strasbourg strasbourg est une ville
qui n'est pas furieusement anti macro
nist il a fait un meeting où les images
d'ailleurs été plus tard il y avait des
gens qui l'interpellaient dans la foule
mais ce n'était pas non plus et je pense
que quand vous verrez la kul la campagne
vous verrez qu'il y aura une progression
dans l'autre sens vers des zones de plus
en plus macro nice pour montrer de plus
en plus de liesse populaire et c'est
normal c'est une stratégie de campagne
habile ça fait partie de ce qu'on doit
faire mais là où je vous rejoins aussi
totalement c'est que les débats en
direct avec les français ça n'a aucun
sens la technocratie ou la techno un
discours technocratique en direct avec
les citoyens ça n'a aucun sens ça ne
peut mener à rien et c'est toute la bbc
la réduction du maquereau nisme qu'on
voit sur ces images là mêmes akrour est
le pur produit de la technocratie
française vraiment les fonds de tiroirs
de bercy parce qu'on va bien d'ailleurs
qu'il a plus beaucoup d'imagination
contrairement à 2017 ça ne marche pas
quand vous essayez de l'expliquer à
hauteur d'1 satisfaction d'individus
c'est impossible et le problème des
magnums macron c'est qu'on peut douter
raisonnablement effectivement
comment dire du credo démocratique de
marine le pen mais c'est que lui c'est
totalement ainsi sur le parlement
totalement ainsi sur les corps
intermédiaires et ce n'est pas parce que
marine le pen a des défauts que ça
efface les siens parce qu'à l'arrivée il
sera élu mais la démocratie française il
l'a lui aussi abîmé et cette question là
elle reste devant michèle cotta qu'ils
descendent dans l'arène qui débattent
avec justement celle ci voyant ça c'est
sa pratique optionnelle du pouvoir c'est
d'aller au delà mais qui n'est pas fini
l'isolation michèle cotta genre sur les
centrales les sièges des mains de
françois mitterrand on peut pas dire que
ce point de vue là où du général de
gaulle en sur une seule différence
effectivement équidés sur le mitterrand
ne sortait pas de bercy c'est
l'alternance c'est vrai mais de l'a31
usage du pouvoir présidentiel alors on
puisse grandir on peut en dire c'est le
parlement sinon vous souvenez comme moi
j'imagine mm bien mieux que moi de la
qualité du personnel parlementaire à
l'époque débat au parlement le contrôle
exercé par le parlement n'ont rien à
voir avec ce qui se passe à dire c'était
mieux avant moi je trouve dans ce
parlement des gens qui savent parler
déjà des jeunes se sont réjouies siens
le contrôle des projets de loi de
finances si vous voulez comprendre dans
le détail de l'insincérité par gmd
je mets juste avoir présidentielle ça
veut dire quelque chose et ça veut dire
que au bout du compte celui qui paye et
les pots cassés et qui recolle justement
les pots cassés c'est le président de la
république voilà c'est comme ça fallait
pas changer de constitution
on a changé on a élu le président
république au suffrage universel c'est
ça que ça donne il faut s'en réjouir ou
au contraire le déplorer alors ils ont
des yeux puis contre 802 réjouissent
tous les deux ont d'ailleurs sur cette
question passé à cette maison avec une
victoire mais un peu à l'américaine pas
de lévis non je voulais seulement dire
que voilà vu de l'étranger en europe
vous êtes une anomalie parce que le
système de la vème république avec un
président élu directement suffrage
universel n'existe nulle part ailleurs
en europe on a tous ailleurs des
systèmes proportionnels
parlementaire avec une grande dose de
proportionnelle cela d'un côté d'un
point de vue théorique et plus
démocratique parce qu'il ya une
représentation au parlement beaucoup
plus profonde mais après ça garantit pas
forcément la stabilité que la le monde
entier vous ennuie parce qu'après on
fait des réformes an pendant cinq ans et
on applique un progrès comme c'est le
cas en france après moi ça fait je suis
maintenant à ma troisième campagne
présidentielle en france et à chaque
fois ça peut être nicolas sarkozy ça
peut être françois hollande ça peut être
emmanuel macron à chaque fois c'est la
même critique c'est-à-dire un président
complètement déconnectés de la réalité
alors je me demande cette déconnexion
prétendu des connexions elle est due à
la personnalité du président ou
peut-être à ce système très verticale
qui éloigne énormément le centre
parisien à la base à mon avis ça peut
être très mal et un maquereau sarkozy
hollande des familles politiques
différentes et c'est à chaque fois c'est
le même constat donc ça aussi un certain
moment il faut s'interroger quand on
fait la radiographie d'un d'un malaise
pro-régime en fait parce que si vous
regardez ce qui est reproché à bruce
johnson actuellement assez l'arenal
vraiment le summum du faites ce que je
dis faites pas ce que je fait de vivre
dans une tour d'ivoire dans laquelle il
pouvait faire des fêtes d'anniversaire
pendant que les autres étaient confinés
je suis pas sûr que mario draghi se soit
invitée l'eau n'est vraiment très
représentatif donc c'est normal pour
d'ivoire on la retrouve un peu partout
c'est très pratique à deux choses qui
joue en fait qu'à la personnalisation du
pouvoir et les institutions françaises
et après il ya l'évolution du monde sert
que le champ du politique il s'est quand
même beaucoup réduit parce que
contrairement aux années 80 à la fois la
libéralisation on a libéralisé beaucoup
de choses d'ailleurs cet effet largement
pendant les années 80 la mondialisation
comme le fait que l'europe se soit
développée et on peut s'en réjouir c'est
un autre débat parce qu'on peut
considérer que la légitimité
démocratique et au parlement bruxellois
enfin à l'arrivée le champ de ce sur
quoi les élus français en la main il
s'est vraiment réduit et on a créé une
espèce de piège parfait parce qu'une
fois qu'on a fait ça dit mais oui le
piège parfait je vais vous dire pourquoi
parce qu'une fois qu'on a fait ça ça
attire moins ça attire et moi je
maintiens que ça n'attire plus les mêmes
profils les gens qui sont ambitieux
aujourd'hui son banquier d'affaires ils
sont triés marque même et y associant
d'armes dans les rues une
autre raison il ya beaucoup d'autres
partick c'est plus drôle et fait partie
de la crise ils sont moins d'argent que
les autres on on est sous le miroir de
tout le monde en est pour voir beaucoup
montrent bien comment ça c'est une tour
spt
justement puisqu'on parle des
institutions une question peut-être à
vous ou michele cotta sur justement ce
spes de chaos politique le fait qu'il
n'y ait plus vraiment deux grands partis
comme donc ce parti de droite
républicaine et ce parti de social
démocrate de gauche est-ce que ça ajoute
je dirais à cette espèce de
présidentialisation au fait que le
président sera encore déconnecté la
question se pose effectivement la
question suppose on voit un président
donc qui fait environ le tiers de gros
tiers tiers de la population et puis une
extrême droite qui fait un petit tiers
et necsa mme bush qui fait un petit
tiers alors luc ferry pose très bien la
question dont beaucoup de ces articles
elle en sait beaucoup de ses papiers est
ce que le fait qu'ils aient un corps
central 1 implique que forcément et à
gauche et à droite un corps radics
radical et c'est un franchement moi je
n'ai pas la réponse et on ne l'a pas
encore on le verra l'aura sans doute au
cours de ce septennat de ce quinquennat
dont ils veulent justement faire un
petit buzz a offert à sète n'est de
toute façon il me semble que la vème
république a maintenant une grande ville
devant derrière elle et que peut-être en
effet il ya quelques moyens
démocratiques a ajouté pour que les
français s'expriment plus souvent
autrement et qui ne s'exprime pas
uniquement par l'abstention alors sur la
politique internationale on va justement
ont parlé un petit peu d'europe emmanuel
macron et
marine le pen est ce que ce sont deux
visions différentes sur l'europe on a
déjà dit oui sur ce plateau mais on va y
revenir on va les écouter on va d'abord
écouté marine le pen puis emmanuel
macron
le frenchy tu n'est nullement notre
projet mais lorsque la grande-bretagne a
quitté l'union européenne la classe
dirigeante française a parlé d'un repli
nationaliste et insulaire et prédit un
cataclysme pour les anglais or il n'en
est rien je le répète ce n'est pas notre
projet nous nous voulons réformer
l'union européenne de l'intérieur mais
plus nous libérerons du carcan
bruxellois tout en restant dans l'union
européenne plus nous nous tournerons
vers le vaste camp il me semble que
c'est ce que les anglais ont bien
compris la bataille que nous menons
n'est pas simplement la france et pour
l'europe parce que le projet d'extrême
droite qui efface à celui que je défends
en votre nom a beaucoup ici présents
c'est un projet
ils se cachent maintenant il est plus
ambiguë mais c'est un projet de sortie
de leur métier doit rester deux europe
oui enfin je pense que l'europe est en
réalité compte pour très peu dans le
vote des français et le vin des français
compte énormément dans l'avenir de
l'europe donc c'est un vrai problème
c'est un problème parce que très souvent
quand vous écoutez à la fois et là mais
je peux vous garantir pour avoir des
quelques années d'avoir écouté des gens
dans des groupes cali en fin
une autre une autre europe cette autre
europe à laquelle tous les hommes
politiques français aspirent et les
électeurs c'est une robe française en
fait c'est l'europe poussé la france en
grand c'est à dire c'est la sécurité
française sécurité sociale française la
culture française à l'exception
culturelle française etc c'est odile
totalement notre bien sûr parce que
c'est un cetain c'est c'est une
ambiguïté qui remontent à l'époque de de
gaulle à 6 on pouvait à peu près faire
ce qu'on voulait avec la politique de la
chaise vide aujourd'hui à 27 en fait on
n'a absolument plus cette marge de
manoeuvre et c'est d'autant plus dommage
que les gens continuent de penser comme
ça que alors pour le coup depuis 2019 le
groupe prix n'y aura pas vraiment les
clés du camion et que du coup il ya un
vrai pouvoir acronis temps louis
borredon il ya un vrai pouvoir là je
pense que makonda jamais autant d'alliés
même les pays les plus rétifs comme les
pays-bas maintenant sûr quand même
d'abord le premier ministre a dû les
groupes prennent une europe aussi en
fait on n'a jamais eu autant chance de
pouvoir faire une europe qui soit pas
peut-être française mais qui soit on va
dire en un sens macro nist donc c'est
sûr que la cie a conduit battue on va
revenir à la situation d'avant à la
crise qui a failli être fatale à
l'europe celle de la crise grecque parce
que là évidemment on va avoir une crise
financière inévitablement tout le monde
le sait marine le pen la première mais
michèle cotta pour emmanuel macron le
scrutin est un référendum sur l'europe
il a dit ça c'est un peu vrai c'est un
peu vrai mais je dois dire que par
rapport à aux critiques sur bruxelles
que nous avons tous entendu tout le
temps dans toutes les campagnes
électorales tous les hommes politiques
de droite et de gauche ont été dès
qu'ils étaient européens opposés à la
question oui mais alors c'est à
bruxelles que tout se passe je crois
qu'il ya quelque chose d'un peu changé
depuis cinq ans c'est d'abord la
réussite de la politique sanitaire
européenne alors que c'était pas dans
les traités la santé n'étaient pas et on
a l'impression que en ayant acheté tous
ces vaccins en même temps et bien on a
le départ on a beaucoup parlé soit la
vente de tous ses échecs des mi'kmaq les
masques oui mais c'est justement quand
la france était seule qui j'ose dire à
partir du moment où il ya eu un
aspirations communes sur les baixas à
changer un peu et ce qui a beaucoup
changé pardon mais c'est d'ukraine fois
sans doute y passer mais l'ukraine a
créé un sentiment européen qui même
lorsqu'ils n'existait qu'à peine olivia
je complète ce que je dis madame un
quota c'est à dire de deux exploits et
un troisième très important et je dirais
même une révolution copernicienne qui
s'est produite en europe ces derniers
deux ans vous n'êtes pas sans savoir que
pendant dix ans vous vous en souvenez ou
pas on a manifesté à rome à paris à
madrid athènes on battait le pavé tout
le temps pour demander une europe de la
croissance de la croissance l'on pouvait
plus de cette europe de la rigueur et de
l'austérité et tout le monde ne pouvait
plus on s'en souvient très bien et
pendant la pandémie il y à un miracle
qui s'est produit et c'est aussi grâce à
la france d' emmanuel macron on a
introduit le plan de relance européen
qui peut paraître technocratique mais
qui dans les fêtes est une forme de
mutualisation de la dette en europe et
c'est une vraie révolution copernicienne
parce que pour la première fois
introduit en europe une pré forme de
fraternité européenne et donc quand les
français ne s'intéressent pas à l'europe
en fait il ne s'intéresse pas à eux
mêmes parce que maintenant après ce
chantier là il y à une autre occasion
extraordinaire c'est le chantier de la
réforme du pacte de stabilité qui est
déjà dans les rails parce qu emmanuel
macron et mario draghi ont annoncé
qu'ils veulent changer le fameux 3% et
dont est donc ça va voir un impact
direct et si je veux tel match on n'est
pas élu tout ça et tout cela ce rythme
annuel mais fort n'en ai pas eu bien sûr
on le sait pas il faut s'interroger sur
le programme de marine le pen déjà sur
les rails
sur le registre elle parle d'europe des
nations elle est ce qu'elle ferait une
politique à la sorbonne
j'ai sûrement ses modèles pense en tout
cas qu'il est absurde de lui reprocher
dans une espèce de fric site cacher
parce que je constate que ni les
polonais ni la hongrie ni l'italie quant
à elle été gouvernée par un mouvement
politique de la même nature ni
l'autriche quand elle a eu aussi un
gouvernement de la même inspiration
m'ont souhaité à aucun moment sortir de
l'europe il ya différentes visions de
l'europe et d'ailleurs sur moi je crois
que l'ukraine a changé quelque chose de
fondamental effectivement parce que dans
ce qu'on s'est rendu compte que l'europe
avait un capital extraordinaire elle
fait envie elle fait envie et le modèle
effectivement de prospérité et de
démocratie libérale ça fait envie à la
moldavie la géorgie aux ukrainiens
s'étaient en revanche ne racontons pas
n'importe quoi la norvège ne fait pas
partie de l'europe la suisse ne fait pas
partie de l'europe liste non plus israël
ont été vaccinées c'est l'opération
world speed et les décisions donald
trump qui font que nous avons des
vaccins vous aurez constaté comme un qui
n'a pas eu de vaccins développés en
europe ni par l'europe ni par les
entreprises fermées centraliser les
achats ni d'ailleurs de traitements
antiviraux en le pacs le vide s'est
encore fait peur et c'est encore aux
états unis ça n'est pas l'europe et la
vaccination elle aurait pu être géré
autrement et elle est très bien gérée
dans d'autres pays après je ne dis pas
que l'europe a mal fait juste cette
absurde sur le plan de relance c'est
pareil
on en arrive là potentiel oui mais c'est
intéressant parce qu avant de
s'intéresser à ce qu'elle propose elle
regardons la réalité de ce que nous
avons sous les yeux parce que moi quand
j'écoute emmanuel macron j'entends quand
même beaucoup d'imprécisions voire de
contre vérités absolues le plan de
relance il ouvre la possibilité de cette
dette commune mais le tant du plan de
relance il épie note je regarde comparer
à 7,5
ont
comparé les 750 milliards d'euros pour
527 millions d'habitants pour 7 527
millions d'habitants
non mais je vous dis que la possibilité
on est amis qui franchement ne sommes
pas dans cette réalité là pour l'instant
et je constate que l'allemagne n'a pas
l'air d'en avoir particulièrement envie
et un certain nombre de pays d'europe du
nord non plus et c'est à peu près le
même nom qu'ils ont renvoyée à monsieur
mâcon quand il souhaitait aller plus
loin donc oui il a incontestablement
fait avancer les choses sauf que pas sur
le terrain du concret et au delà de ça
je veux dire leur pelle sonde était tous
les pays sont
tous les pays sans d'été très bien
chacun de leur côté on n'avait pas
besoin en espèces juste de ça mais ça
veut pas dire qu'il faille pas le faire
c'est à dire que le vrai sujet européen
mais sa marine le pen ne se prononce pas
tu sais qu'il ya une ambiguïté absolue à
avoir une zone monétaire commune à gérer
la politique budgétaire d'un côté et des
politiques est offert les budgétaire
dans chacun des pays et la politique
monétaire de l'autre parce que la
coordination budgétaire celle là ne se
fait pas et ça n'a aucun chance de
disjoindre le monétaire du but matt
edwards et mais marine le pen
effectivement elle proposa une europe
des nations elle veut d'ailleurs son
lien avec l'allemagne est très
particulier d'hier dans sa conférence de
presse ne veut pas vraiment de
coopération militaire avec avec
l'allemagne bon elle a quand même des
alliés auxerre qui sont le premier
ministre hongrois mais la france n'est
pas la hongrie en fait la hongrie c'est
un pays extrêmement vieillissant il ya
moins de 1 de taux de natalité est donc
en fait il ya zéro immigrés en fait
concrètement en hongrie aussi là nous si
elle est élue dès la 10e minute dans les
boums et surtout la chose quand on prend
pas c'est que la france et le centre de
l'europe mots vous avez aussi un rôle de
locomotive en europe la hongrie je suis
désolé c'est un grand pays mais c'est
pas un des pays fondateurs de la france
et l'europe même le moteur se
chercheront des arrivages ici à paris
aura en revanche pas juste une ligne
mais qui pas tellement de clivages et je
trouve que là aussi la l'actualité a
amené les deux d'ailleurs et que ce et
macro et marine le pen à se dire qu'il
fallait réindustrialiser la france que
c'était le
reproche qu'on pouvait faire à lens hier
à l'europe telle qu'elle était avant
c'est vrai qu'une europe qui des intrus
sera lise est une europe qui n'existe
plus et on voit très bien comment la
france maintenant
après ce après ces deux graves conflits
se dit il est temps de faire revenir les
gens chez nous donc il ya peut-être
presque 1,1 point commun entre les deux
non pas sur le souverainisme mais sur la
nécessité que la france ne soit pas ne
le donne pas cette entreprise à
n'importe qui et n'importe où alors on
parlait du conflit justement en ukraine
comment se fait-il mathieu doiret que
finalement marine le pen n'est pas payer
plus que ça finalement sont ses liens
avec vladimir poutine dans un premier
temps quand même il ya eu un moment où
ça a pénalisé quand même tous les
candidats soupçonnés et surtout eric
zemmour fils avaient péri mais juste
titre parce que c'est le seul qui n'a
pas fermé honorable sur ce sujet puisque
elle a quand même très vite dit qu'elle
cautionnait pas l'invasion de l'ukraine
non la réalité c'est que comme toujours
les électeurs aussi bien en france
qu'ailleurs se prononce pas en réalité
sur les questions de politique étrangère
si ce n'est est-ce que ce qui se passe
au niveau international risquent d'avoir
un impact sur ma vie quotidienne et très
vite ils se sont focalisés sur le
principal impact sur la vie quotidienne
qui était le coût de l'énergie donc tous
et des centres et ensuite tout est allé
sur la question du pouvoir d'achat parce
que la réalité du vote de peine c'est
que les gens ne veulent pas une autre
europe s'ils veulent pas une robe
poutinienne urbanienne ce qu'ils veulent
c'est une france où on puisse vivre
mieux entre guillemets sans avoir
nécessairement entre guillemets à en
payer le prix or leurs soupçons c'est
que l'europe que ma qu'on propose c'est
une grotte dans laquelle les français
vont devoir continuer à se serrer la
ceinture parce que finalement ce thème
là extrêmement populaire aussi bien dans
la partie peu plus de gauche que dans la
partie peu plus voire d'achat donc mais
bien sur le principe c'est qu'est ce
qu'on pourrait faire alors elle a des
solutions qui sont en apparence simple
il s'est notamment deux de pointe et le
poids de la tva tva sur justement les
produits bien dit ça c'est extrêmement
simple et populaire tout le monde
comprend le problème en ville en réalité
sur lequel on va attendre vacances et de
l'ue de d'exposer pourquoi ça ne
marchera pas mais dans l'absolu c'est
elle est construite autrement
notre fiscalité n'est pas construit
comme ça mais parce que non mais c'est
comme quoi même si la composition
rigueur le pen quand on regarde le
nombril et agira d manueel mâcon celui
que je suis d'accord avec quoi qu'il en
coûte le match jusque cet argument n'a
aucun sens parce que on pourrait
parfaitement envisager
soit construit différents mais on
pourrait surtout mettre de l'ordre dans
les finances publiques français et il me
semble d'ailleurs c'est la première oui
mais
quand même remettre de l'ordre dans les
finances françaises voilà précisément
parce qu'il ya pas de contrôle
démocratique c'est encore précisément
parce que le parlement ne contrôle pas
l'exécution des lois de finances et
parlementaire sur les capable de lever
mais si je sais pas si les parlements en
attendant il en version leur donner les
éléments pour le faire je vous assure
que ça sera mieux contrôlé je vous
assure que dans la plupart des
démocrates vont revenir justement au
pouvoir d'achat parce qu'il ne reste
plus beaucoup de temps donc face à cette
mesure que propose marine le pen donc de
baisser la tva ou même de les supprimer
complètement sur un certain nombre de
produits première nécessité emmanuel
macron propose une chose c'est de
traiter la prime en fait macro mais
c'est tout donc est-ce qu effectivement
là il ya une sorte de faiblesse du côté
des manuels macron sûr
dans notre système actuel si on
fait tomber c'est tout là elle vient il
faut autant d'argent pour trouver
ailleurs pour remplir les caisses donc
on les trouve si on les trouve si déjà
on augmente les impôts si on entend des
impôts on était encore plus impopulaire
donc c'est pas tout de dire un il faut
baisser les taxes c'est pas tout parce
qu'après faut remplir autrement les
caisses de l'état alors on se débrouille
ça c'est un choix on peut dire oui on
fait payer les riches comme l'a très
bien dit
jean luc mélenchon il dit à 350
milliards de dette et ben moi je fais
350 milliards économie c'est fini ça on
peut le dire en revanche quand on est à
droite c'est difficile de dire on monte
les impôts et et vous voyez ça
et vous allez payer moins cher que les
gens quand même sont pas idiots en tout
cas si ça ne leur a pas échappé non plus
que la france est arrivé à quasiment 66%
de sa richesse nationale consacrée la
dépense publique sert plus ou moins le
même niveau que là où on est l urss
tu as vraiment de dépenses publiques
c'était valérie pécresse donc à lyon
mais je peux pas partir du principe que
rien n'est possible parce que nous
faisons pas d'élection de nom les clés à
la terre ça se passe alors un dernier
mot puisqu'il nous reste 5 minutes sur
les retraites paulo je me tourne vers
vous parce que tu m'as eu de réforme des
retraites en italie alors là bon il ya
un vrai clivage 62 ans pour marine le
pen voire 60 ans dans certaines
conditions 65 ans emmanuel macron mais
il a dit que ça serait pas un dogme et
peut-être 64 comment votre perception
mais ma perception c'est que les ja je
peux vous dire qu'en france vous êtes
les seuls qui ont encore en europe une
retraite à 62 ans nous on est à 67 et ça
nous paraît déjà extraordinaire parce
que ça risque d aberdeen r oui parce que
est-ce que ça risquait d'aller même au
delà d'ailleurs vous êtes le pays de
descartes il y a une espérance de vie
guy qui a s'est énormément a grandi
pendant ces derniers 20 ans donc un
certain moment il faut faire en sorte
que les comptes soient soit carré et
donc emmanuel macron céder sa grande
promesse pendant le premier quinquennat
il a mis tout ça dans le congélateur un
cause pendant la crise des gilets jaunes
et ensuite il ya eu la pandémie est là
il revient et on a vu déjà que l'autre
jour il a pour la première
rétrospective et avec cette idée de
faire une petite ristourne danon donc de
passer de 65 à 64 en tout cas c'est le
merveilleux monde de l'amélie poulain
parce que vous êtes le seul pays
et encore même si c'était à 65 sa
surface toutes
ces électeurs de
65 ans
de toute façon il y aura une bataille
des retraites elle est obligatoire quand
c'est aussi une façon de rider carte ou
pas mais c'est aussi une façon de sauver
le système par répartition sinon ça
n'existe mais nos enquêtes pillac
épisode montre qu'on n'est plus vraiment
le pays de descartes crois qu'on est en
quête de l' ocde un des pays où le moins
de gens savent répondre à la question si
je place 100 euros à 10 % d'intérêts
comme dangereux ou d'un an
et ce cas-ci merci à ça que se heurtent
les hommes politiques en france et
en cours de classement des universités
de shanghaï c'est ça on voudrait plus
forts à shanghai
on refera le sujet sans éducation le
débat sur l'éducation n'a plus de temps
mais ça c'est un plein un épouvantail
français puisque la réalité c'est qu'on
pouvait parfaitement rester dans quelque
chose ou on allonge et des trimestres
que la question de l'âge c'était le cas
ce que je vous dis je ne crois pas qu'il
y avait ainsi une si grande urgence
c'est à dire que la réforme des
retraites celle au totem et le tabou du
débat politique française pour certains
c'est le totem pour d'autres c'est le
tabou mais c'est assez at shirt quand on
raisonne sur les finances publiques
françaises on pouvait très bien ne pas
se livrer épuisé un capital politique de
dengue et au delà ça il y avait quand
même un accord à un moment la cfdt était
d'accord avec le projet qui était celui
de la réforme systémique et puis edouard
philippe dans sa grande sagesse sont
grands génies que chacun lui connaît a
voulu introduire la réforme paramétrique
et puis là pouf patatras tout alors
qu'il y avait déjà eu je ne sais combien
d'années de concerts débats et partir
dans la même ce sont la même folie sur
est le seul syndicat à s'être déclarés
pour emmanuel macron donc je suppose que
quand même comme il est comme ils n'ont
pas tout à fait fou il pense que la
retraite le sujet de la retraite
s'inscrira sûrement dans le débat non
mais je l'espère aujourd'hui ce qu'on
s'est infligé beaucoup de beaucoup
d'auto douleur politiser le dossier date
pour finalement pas grand chose merci
beaucoup en tout cas michèle cotta jean
sébastien ferjou merci mathieu doiret
merci paolo levi merci à vous tous de
nous avoir suivis et reste avec nous sur
france 24
[Musique]